[Music]
on this Saturday night strep a
infections and tragic consequences
Dr influenza there's a larger chance of
people getting group a streptococcal
infection the country seeing cases rise
in children and the symptoms parents
should look for loaded guns in carry-ons
spotted by security all over the U.S in
record numbers hidden in unusual spots
when you're at the gas station there was
only gas welcome to the future of gas
stations
yeast our DNA and the moon an ambitious
Canadian teams experiment to test human
life outside Earth
global national with para Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
strep a is common and relatively minor
it's a bacteria found in the throat or
on our skin that can cause a fever or a
throat infection it's rarely invasive
but what it is it can be dangerous and
it can spread quickly two children under
two have died in Montreal from invasive
strep a several countries are now
investigating a surge in cases
especially among children Mike drolet
has our top story tonight in the signs
parents should look for
in Montreal two children under the age
of two have died as a result of invasive
strep a in the UK 16 children have died
over the past few months and in the U.S
the Center for Disease Control is
investigating a sudden rise in bacterial
infections the numbers aren't
overwhelming but Public Health agencies
are still asking the question why are we
seeing more cases this year the short
answer is we don't know but it's it it's
not it wouldn't be surprising if this
was in relation to a large burden of
influenza another respiratory viral
infections we know and we've known for
decades that there's an association that
after influenza there's a larger there's
a larger chance of people getting group
a streptococcal infections three weeks
ago nine-year-old Ayla lozeth was taking
Kelowna ER doctors treated her for the
influenza virus but her symptoms
worsened after returning home and she
ultimately died from strep a
the bacterial infection is dangerous
when it becomes invasive and moves into
the bloodstream causing sepsis it's also
hard to recognize because its earliest
symptoms fever and sore throat are
similar to the flu
less common symptoms include scarlet
fever scabs and sores as well as joint
pain and swelling and in severe cases
pneumonia the World Health Organization
and the CDC say the risk to the general
public is currently low Public Health
meanwhile is telling doctors to be aware
and Advising parents to take the
precautions we've all become familiar
with you know the vaccine of course
isn't perfect but it can mitigate the
severity of influenza and uh and that'll
go a long way and obviously protecting
from the flu and all its complications
and then of course it will also protect
against many of the downstream effects
that we know can happen after the flu
like secondary bacterial infections
including group a Streptococcus the vast
majority of children who get strep a
will avoid serious complications and
invasive strep a when caught early is
treatable with antibiotics microlyte
Global News Toronto
a Meningitis outbreak is being declared
at the Dalhousie University Residence
building following the death of a
student two other cases of students who
live in the same residence are being
investigated Nova Scotia Public Health
says it is investigating if there was
any contact between the two but adds
there is no risk to the general public
as this form of bacterial meningitis is
not spread through the air or casual
contact
hundreds of people including a who's who
of Canadian politicians attended the
funeral for a long time Winnipeg MP Jim
Carr today he died earlier this week
from cancer prime minister Justin
Trudeau as well as past and present
cabinet ministers and even political
opponents all attended to pay their
respects as Tegan Russia reports the
service was exactly what Carr wanted
[Music]
from the music the life can only be
truly appreciated and well lived
by someone who appreciates its brevity
to the Jewish wisdom to The Venue every
part of Jim Carr's memorial service was
chosen by him something he did after his
terminal cancer diagnosis three years
ago he was extraordinary and we are we
are bereft but we are better for having
known him for better for having had him
serve this country Carr served as the MP
for Winnipeg South Central since 2015. a
job he worked right to the very end Jim
kind of understood the bigness of this
country he understood how big it is and
how sometimes we've got to make
compromises but that doesn't mean that
we aren't principled even between
chemotherapy dialysis and a bone marrow
transplant the 71 year old never stopped
fighting for Canadians just days before
he passed his private member's Bill
building a green Prairie economy passed
through the chamber that's Jim's Spirit
right there bring me people together a
fierce Canadian a proud Westerner a
loyal winnipegger and somebody who was
always teaching the Next Generation how
to um how to be good at what they do
Carr had many hobbies and was fondly
remembered outside of his work in Ottawa
he once played the oboe professionally
performing right on this stage
Carr is also praised for the work he did
with underrepresented groups I know that
we always had his support his unwavering
support for First Nations and trying to
to change this country and has been it's
gonna he's gonna be missed he was such a
progressive thinker and a dear friend
Carr somber memorial service ended in a
memorable way for his family the Prime
Minister handing them the Canadian flag
that flew on the peace Tower the descar
passed along with a copy of his last
bill which officially became a law on
Thursday Tegan Russia Global News
Hockey Canada's provincial and
territorial members have elected a new
board of directors though it happened at
the organization's annual winter meeting
retired judge and former Olympic
sprinter Hugh Frazier is the new chair
while former Women's National team
captain Cassie Campbell Pascal will fill
one of the other nine seats the previous
board stepped down in October following
controversy related to how it handled
sexual assault allegations and payouts
to victims
Quebec's coroner is investigating the
death of a woman following plastic
surgery she passed away last month
almost two weeks after the surgery and
it's unclear why it happened but it is
Raising questions about the safety of
complicated surgeries in private clinics
Amanda gillowicki has more
hi we're doing a tummy tuck here today
plastic surgeon Dr Sandra McGill has
worked in West Mount for years now she
owns the private Surgical Clinic at
spass MD her website indicates she
performs all types of surgeries from
tummy tucks to liposuction well her
Clinic is now part of an investigation
that's because a patient died last month
after surgery
McGill's spokesman wouldn't comment
we're not allowed to communicate any
information about our patients sources
tell Global News the patient was in her
40s she had surgery for abdominal
liposuction the patient underwent
sedation under the care of a respiratory
technician
at some point during surgery sources say
the patient's Health deteriorated and
she suffered a lack of oxygen
she was rushed to the Montreal general
hospital
she never regained Consciousness and
died almost two weeks later her cause of
death is unknown but Quebec's coroner is
investigating in a statement the
coroner's office said we confirm that an
investigation into this death is
underway to shed light on the causes and
circumstances surrounding the death
the death has left Montreal's close-knit
plastic surgery Community reeling
doesn't happen often so there's a quite
a shock our colleagues wanted to know
what happened they want to understand
what happened plastic surgery related
deaths are rare in Quebec the College of
Physicians says only two in the last
decade well it suddenly happened it
barely never happened in aesthetic we
won't operate someone who needs or
whatever to say so we'll take someone in
during good health and the surgery what
we do is is mostly what we call
superficial garate said no one should
speculate on why the woman died he said
private clinics follow rigid standards
for certification and are safe the
coroner's inquest should shed more light
on what happened and if the death could
have been prevented Amanda jelawicki
Global News Montreal
with Parliament adjourned for the
holidays some important discussions on
Firearms policy are on hold until the
new year last month the federal
government proposed new amendments to
its gun control legislation Bill c21
seeking to expand the definition of its
ban on assault-style weapons that could
affect hunting rifles a number of
Canadians including some indigenous
groups have found the bill to be
controversial for the West block our
Mercedes Stevenson looks at the reaction
to these potential revisions Mercedes
for the liberal's decision to add an
amendment to bill c21 which was
originally aimed in large part at
Banning handguns as many Canadians up in
arms while Ottawa says the changes are
not aimed at law-abiding gun owners
critics say Public Safety and reducing
gun crime are not what's driving this
change the backlash has been Swift and
widespread coming from indigenous groups
Hunters provincial and territorial
governments and opposition MPS critics
say Ottawa is overstepping with the
recent Amendment and that it will end up
Banning long guns used and designed
primarily for hunting this week on the
west block we speak with Public Safety
Minister Marco menduccino about what his
goal is with this amendment and what
compromises he's willing to make that
are operating we all I think are united
in the common cause to eradicate gun
violence it is hard work it is
emotionally charged at times which is
why we want to take the temperature down
and have a debate that that is based on
facts and not fear the minister is
calling for an open dialogue about
potential Bill revisions and says he
doesn't want to play politics but
critics say that the way the government
introduced this amendment was not open
or transparent we'll ask the minister
where the sudden change came from and
why and of course for Marco Mendicino
it's not just gun crime that the public
safety Minister has to worry about
foreign interference is posing a greater
threat to Canada's national security
including concerns about China trying to
influence Canadian politics and
interfering on Canadian soil the
minister told me he's aware of the
threats foreign interference poses to
democratic institutions in Canada but he
wouldn't say whether Canadian counter
Espionage legislation will be upgraded
to include hostile foreign actor laws
something the UK is looking into well I
think we're you know keeping the options
open
um look I think it's really important
for your viewers and for Canadians to
know that we are at a point in our
national security landscape where there
are threats abound when it comes to
foreign interference we'll have more of
that conversation on the west block plus
we sit down with the defense minister
Anita Anand who gets personal about the
challenges of trying to change military
culture and her pledge to implement the
48 recommendations the former Supreme
Court Justice Louise Arbor has made
we'll also talk about the challenges the
Canadian Forces are facing when it comes
to personnel and equipment and what that
means for the military's ability to
fight in a changing world pharah
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
Mercedes
in the U.S Firearms also making the news
but related to your luggage
coming up why officials feel the need to
tell passengers to pack clothes not guns
this holiday season
after drawing major backlash for
suspending Twitter accounts of prominent
journalists CEO Elon Musk has reversed
course the billionaire reinstated
journalist from CNN the New York Times
and other outlets today after conducting
a basic Twitter poll on the issue that
wasn't before his bands sparked wide
condemnation including from the United
Nations and the European Union over what
many Saw as an attack on press freedoms
the suspensions were related to the
reporting of publicly available data on
musk's private jet
you'd think this is a very easy rule to
follow don't secretly bring a deadly
weapon on board an airplane yet as the
U.S enters an extremely busy holiday
season Transportation safety officials
there are on high alert for passengers
trying to get their guns through airport
security some of them loaded a record
number of weapons have already been
seized this year and as Jennifer Johnson
reports some have been found in the most
unusual places
with over 8 million people expected to
travel through America's airports this
holiday season the U.S Transportation
safety administration is sending out
this warning pack your clothes and not
your guns over 6 300 guns have been
confiscated at TSA checkpoints so far
this year a record most passengers tell
us when we discover their their firearm
in the carry-on bag that they forgot it
was there while most plead ignorance
others go to Great Lanes to hide their
guns officers have found one weapon
hidden in a PlayStation and another
stuffed inside a raw chicken TSA agents
screen about 5.5 million bags a day and
when they find your gun you're not
getting it back we keep it in the
scanner because you know we don't want
anyone or the person that does have it
if they do have ill intent to grab it
and use it in a public area what's even
more alarming is that most of the guns
found 88 of them are loaded
officials say the airports with the
highest numbers of guns seized are
Atlanta and Dallas but now Asheville has
the highest per passenger ratio in a
country where the number of guns
outnumber the number of people the TSA
is urging all passengers to double check
their bags and leave the Firearms at
home clearly you cannot bring a firearm
into a checkpoint you cannot bring a
firearm onto an aircraft the firearm
problem is just one more Cog in the
wheel after a horrendous air travel Gear
with staff and pilot shortages causing
record numbers of delays and
cancellations and fears more wintry
weather could make things even worse
during Peak holiday travel days next
week pointless at being mad about it
just you go to the airport you know
you're going to wait
expected passengers caught with Firearms
at airports face local criminal charges
and civil fines but the problem has
gotten so bad the agency is now raising
the federal fine up to fifteen thousand
dollars for bringing a gun to a TSA
checkpoint
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
tourists that are stranded across Peru
are finding ways to leave the country as
political protests persist
that's great
key roads have been blocked and airports
forced to close the demonstrations come
after former president Pedro Castillo's
removal from office and arrest last week
protesters are calling for early
elections and the new president's
resignation Kamloops BC resident Landon
Evans was traveling through the area
earlier this week he was four and a half
hours away from Lima when his trip was
disrupted by protesters
and I did have to get off the bus and
yeah I was pretty freaked out because
again I don't speak any Spanish
so and I was in a town or
no one I don't think anyone would have
spoken English
Evans is hoping to fly home from Lima to
Vancouver by Monday at the latest to get
there he says he has to ride on a dune
buggy through the desert for two hours
and then find a ride to the Capitol
ahead the future of gas stations what
services will soon be needed at the
pumps to keep customers lining up
[Music]
electric vehicles are changing the way
we drive so what does that mean for the
gas stations we use Kyle Benning looks
at how one company is expanding fueling
options and how it could change the
services you get at your local gas
station
for a growing number of drivers the way
they fuel their car is changing now the
traditional gas station is having to
change too when you're at the gas
station there was only Gas Electric
Mobility Canada says there is an
opportunity for an update EV batteries
generally take longer to charge think
half an hour versus a few minutes for a
petroleum vehicle there can be some kind
of a allowance for people to work in a
place where they can eat something other
than just a frozen sandwich shell is one
of the companies looking ahead it's
buying 56 gas stations owned by grocery
giant Sobe's parent company Empire
shells as it wants to grow the retail
side of its business as well as making
electric charging ports and hydrogen
pumps more available across western
Canada in a similar move Parkland Corp
says it will be installing 50 Ultra fast
charging ports at Chevron stations
across BC and Alberta
and while there's a lot of optimism
about the changing face of service
stations there is hesitancy buying
existing gas stations isn't necessarily
in any energy transition in any way it's
an investment in the status quo the
University of Alberta's John Parkin says
rather than investing in new
infrastructure the company could be
increasing its footprint in western
Canada this also comes after a Dutch
Court ruling ordered shell to reduce its
2019 emissions Levels by 45 percent by
2030 divesting from oil production will
achieve that goal Parkin says those
already with a strong holding in the
sector ultimately won't Shake It Up the
transition really happens with new
players new new new uh new companies new
ideas that enter the market Electric
Mobility says EV sales grew by 68
percent in the third quarter of 2022
against the same period in 2021 Kyle
Benning Global News
next it already gives beer its kick and
bread its bounce now yeast is finding
its way to space and aiding in the
future of travel
[Music]
yeast is probably best known for its
role in making bread and beer but little
known fact when it comes to our genes we
actually share a surprising number of
them with this microscopic fungus and
it's a link researchers at the
University of British Columbia are now
looking into but not for food to
potentially help shape the future of
human space travel Paul Johnson explains
Cosmic radiation is a problem it's a
challenge to anything that's alive it's
not a stretch to say that Corey nislow
and his team at UBC are working on
something essential if human
civilization is ever going to spread
Beyond planet Earth our DNA will get
damaged we know that and liftoff of
Artemis one a few weeks ago nislo's
experiment launched in the Orion capsule
an uncrewed moonshot that's a test for
NASA's Artemis program which will see
humans not only return to the moon but
live there but extended living beyond
Earth's protective magnetic field may
not be possible unless they figure out
the radiation problem so nestled in that
capsule was a colony of common brewers
yeast that mislo set up to grow in Space
by learning how Cosmic radiation on
these trips to the moon and Beyond
affect yeast genes we we can very
rapidly extrapolate that information to
human genes Splashdown and when the most
ambitious project of your career hinges
on a safe return from a trip around the
Moon that's some real pressure I can't
say that it wasn't nerve-wracking news
lows flying to Florida next week to
retrieve the yeast and start the
analysis knowledge that may benefit
Humanity in profound ways and maybe some
simple ones too will we be able to use
some of this yeast to make beer well
I don't see why not Paul Johnson Global
News
yeast who knew and that's global
national for this Saturday night I'm far
enough sir and on behalf of our whole
crew I want to thank so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your Canada is this beautiful
sunrise over the stalamus chief mountain
in Squamish BC lovingly known as the
chief we love seeing your photos so
please keep emailing them to viewers at
globalnational.com until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]
thank you